was wir erlebt haben in der Pandemie
im Hinblick auf den Umgang mit den
unimpften das war so schlimm ich hätte
das nicht für möglich gehalten Menschen
Mitbürger wurden diskriminiert
ausgegrenzt sie wurden bedroht und sie
wurden in ihrem sein als Menschen und
Bürger entwertet und das vor unserer
aller Augen
die es gab eine sprachliche Gewalt die
sich gegen die ungeimpften gerichtet hat
die im Grunde genommen unerträglich war
und mit dieser Gewalt diese Gewalt hat
sich vollzogen über einen langen
Zeitraum und was mich schockiert hat war
wie wir als Gesellschaft damit
umgegangen sind wir haben nämlich
hingenommen wir haben nicht hingeschaut
wir haben im Gegenteil das ganze sogar
in Teilen zumindest auch noch
unterstützt und ähm entschuldigung aber
der Druck war viel zu groß von allen
Seiten ob du reisen wolltest oder da der
Mensch wurde er nur noch überschüttet
mit diesem Wahnsinn
du sprichst eine sehr guten Punkt an es
gab einen wirklich unfassbaren Druck und
man muss fragen woher kommt wo es her
ist dieser Druck gekommen der Druck kam
von zentralen Teilbereichen unserer
Gesellschaft unserer Demokratie im
Grunde genommen alle zentralen
Schutzräume die eine Demokratie bietet
einer Gruppe die sozusagen unterdrückte
Familie in grenzt wird und so weiter
ausgegrenzt wird die waren zerfallen von
der Politik ja ging ein unfassbarer
Druck aus auf der einen Seite die Justiz
hat meines Erachtens nicht mehr recht im
Sinne des Rechts gesprochen sondern
recht im Sinne der Politik das ist fatal
für ein Rechtsstaat es gab sicherlich
auch Ausnahmen ja aber meine Wahrnehmung
war weite Teile der Justiz haben
furchtbar gehandelt und dann natürlich
auch die Medien Medien muss man ganz
schwere Vorwürfe machen Journalisten
haben einen enormen Druck auch auf die
Politik aufgebaut und sie haben sich
quasi als sehr Spitze der
pandemiebekämpfung verstanden und da
muss ich sagen das ist nicht die Aufgabe
von Journalisten Journalisten die
Aufgabe von Journalisten ist sachlich
objektiv und sauber zu berichten der
wahrheitsgemäß und der Realität gemäß
und ich kann verstehen wenn Journalisten
sind ja wir sind alle Menschen die einen
hatten mehr Angst vor Corona die anderen
weniger und ich kann verstehen wenn
Journalisten in ihren Redaktionen Angst
hatten ja vor dem Virus das ist das eine
aber wenn sie nicht in der Lage sind so
zu berichten wie sie Auftrag ist dann
sind sie für den Beruf des Journalisten
nicht geeignet und mein Eindruck war es
gab hier sehr viele Journalisten die auf
eine unerträgliche Art und Weise
Anführungszeichen berichtet haben
sie lassen Sie uns mal bei den
ungeimpften bleiben denn das ist ihr
zentrales Thema jetzt gerade auch in der
Sendung haben sie das selber erlebt die
Vermehrung Ausgrenzung weil sie
ungeimpft sind ja ich habe das vor allen
Dingen erlebt
in meinem Bekanntenkreis also im
Hinblick auf andere ungeimpfte wie mit
denen umgegangen wurde ja es war
furchtbar also ich kann Ihnen zwei
Beispiele nennen eine Freundin
im Kindergarten gearbeitet
jeden Tag kam die Kollegen an und haben
sie gefragt nach ihrem im Status und
haben Druck aufgebaut immer wieder ja
freundlich weniger freundlich mal zum
Ziel mal sehr sehr direkt und ja diese
Frau hat irgendwann diesen Druck nicht
mehr Stand gehalten sie wollte sich
nicht impfen lassen sie war unheimlich
skeptisch gegenüber der Impfung und hat
sich dann zweimal spritzen lassen und
das hat auch etwas beschädigt in diesem
Menschen dieser Frau und das ist ein
Beispiel ein anderes Beispiel war
einfach im Hinblick auf die Maßnahmen
einer junge Frau die keine Maske tragen
konnte aus medizinischen Gründen also
real faktisch keine Maske tragen die Art
und Weise wie der Arbeitgeber mit dir
umgegangen ist was so unerträglich so
schlimm sie hatte einen
Nervenzusammenbruch auf der Arbeit und
Krankenwagen musste kommen und sie ist
jetzt in Therapie das sind einfach zwei
Fälle aus meinem direkten Umfeld die ich
mitbekommen habe live erlebt habe das
heißt die Fälle die ich jetzt gezielt
habe haben sich auf der
gesellschaftlichen Ebene vollzogen und
die Frage ist wie konnte es dazu kommen
dass Arbeitskollegen ja mit denen man
einen Moment noch ja wunderbar
zusammengearbeitet habe plötzlich sich
angemaßt haben in einer medizinische
Entscheidung die Privatsache ist
einzugreifen sie haben gerade den Kopf
richtig in die Hände gelegt und sagten
flüsterten so leise das kenne ich auch
also was ich erlebt habe war der
Bäckerei also da gab es anscheinend
jemand der hat es nicht vertragen auch
und der hat die Maske wirklich also das
kann man die da unten getragen und ist
dann eben so rein und ich saß da eben
und der wurde wirklich von allen Seiten
also gut von dieser Verkäuferin die muss
es machen weil sonst kriegt sie
wahrscheinlich fliegt sie aus ihrem Job
raus das weiß ich aber das sind wirklich
fünf sechs Leute auf den Namen auf den
eingeschimpft auf diesen Menschen der
erklärte er hat erstmal er konnte das
irgendwie nicht gut manchmal machen das
vielleicht weil sie keine Maske tragen
wollen dem habe ich aber echt abgenommen
der Typ ist total verstört dass dieser
wirklich wie so eine Masse auf diesen
Menschen los
auch darüber geschrieben sie haben sich
mit vielen Menschen unterhalten wie die
Menschen die corona-krise erlebt haben
wie sie Ausgrenzung Einsamkeit Isolation
erlebt haben Familien sind daran
auseinander gebrochen was wurde Ihnen
geschildert im Zuge ihrer Recherche ja
es wurde ein Teil in die Gesellschaft
getrieben und zwar massiv
also wenn ich nur daran denke ich meine
der Titel des Buches heißt lautet möge
die gesamte Republik mit dem Finger auf
sie zeigen das ist ein Zitat das
Redakteurs man hochrangiger Journalist
ehemalige stellvertretender
Chefredakteur der Bild-Zeitung der das
gesagt hat möge die gesamte Republik auf
die ungeimpften ja genau
kommt aus dem dezember 2020 da standen
wir ja vor dem zweiten harten Lockdown
geschlossen das muss man zur Einordnung
dazu sagen und das war wenige Tage bevor
die ersten Menschen geimpft wurden ich
möchte nur dass wir diese
Erkenntnisstand genau absolut also es
gut einzuordnen es macht es nicht besser
man muss sich mal vorstellen was das
heißt wenn jemand von uns irgendetwas
tut sozusagen eine moralische
Grenzüberschreitung oder so ja und
jemand sagt ja ich muss jetzt mit dem
Finger auf Dich zeigen das ist ja
peinlich das tut ja weh ist irgendwie
auch schlimm wenn ein Journalist der
eine Verantwortung hat gegenüber ja auch
der Öffentlichkeit wenn der zu so einem
drastischen Sprachbild greifen er ist so
krass dich formuliert das eine gesamte
Republik auf die Menschen zeigt die
nicht geimpft sind dann hat das eine
enorme Wucht und hier ist das ist meines
Erachtens eine massive journalistische
Grenzüberschreitung auch wenn das im im
Rahmen der Meinungsfreiheit in Ordnung
ist ja ich bin keiner der irgendwie sagt
man soll so etwas verbieten aber
ja hier wurde meines Erachtens gehetzt
bis zum geht nicht mehr viele Menschen
schildern dass sie sich an den Pranger
gestellt haben während der
corona-pandemie wie hast du das
empfunden wie hast du auch die Sprache
empfunden und das Umgehen miteinander
empfunden in dieser Zeit ich war ja
selber jemand der ungeimpfte oder Leute
die sich nicht haben impfen lassen
kritisiert hat auch hier ich habe zum
Beispiel Joshua Kimmich für seine für
seine Haltung stark kritisiert warum
haben Sie das gemacht wenn ich fragen
darf weil ich weil ich der Meinung war
dass jemand der teilnimmt an einem
an einer Veranstaltung wo sich alle
impfen lassen mussten um daran
teilzunehmen was kann die Zuschauer gab
wo alle auch
gefährdet waren nach damaligen
Kenntnissen vielleicht kann ich da
gleich noch einen Satz zu sagen nach
damaligen Kind sich zu infizieren ist
dann auch aus meiner Perspektive ein Akt
der ja der Ungerechtigkeit war von
Kimmich zu sagen ich kümmere mich nicht
nur um mich selbst sondern wir sind auch
alle anderen egal so habe ich das damals
gewesen ich habe das nachher allerdings
revidiert ich ist meine Meinung dann
auch öffentlich geändert hat mir nicht
viel Zuspruch eingebracht wie das eine
noch das andere aber dann bin ich klüger
geworden nur noch einmal zurück vor drei
Jahren um diese Zeiten ja 2000 gab es 59
Fälle in Wuhan die auf einmal aufkamen
wo man gesagt hat oder gibt es Leute mit
irgendwelchen Symptomen das ist so ein
bisschen wie Lungenentzündung wir wissen
nicht was das ist die Chinesen haben
eine Stadt mit 11 Millionen Menschen im
Buren dicht gemacht
Aktien sind in den Keller gerauscht
Trump hat eine Reise nach Europa
geschaut
die Formel 1 hörte auf zu fahren es
waren wenn überhaupt Geisterspiele in
der Pandemie und 4 Milliarden Menschen
waren im April also drei Monate später
zu Hause mussten zu Hause bleiben und
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat
erklärt das ist eine Pandemie die es
noch nie gegeben hat und wir wussten
alle nicht was tut dieser Virus also
vielleicht auch das als Erklärung wie
man damals rangegangen ist und
beurteilt hat ich habe allerdings meine
Haltung dann sage ich jetzt nicht
irgendwie um mit dem Beifall irgendwo
abzuholen aber es war einfach so dass
ich dann doch gesagt habe nein hier muss
man auch mit sowas zulassen was war der
Grund für ihre der Grund war dass das
immer klarer wurde dass Corona
offenkundig eine Krankheit ist die nicht
allein mit Impfung zu besiegen ist was
uns ja suggeriert wurde am Anfang der
hieß es ja
genau dann kriegt er es nicht ja und
dann war das durch impfen lasst euch
noch mal impfen dann kam dieser berühmte
Satz von der Drosten der beste Schutz
ist dreimal infiziert zu sein möglichst
schwer und sich viermal impfen zu lassen
einfach absolut so und da habe ich
angefangen zu denken Mensch was passt
denn hier nicht zusammen müssen sich die
Verantwortlichen Deiner Ansicht nach bei
den ungeimpften entschuldigen wenn man
Schuld auf sich geladen hat ist
entschuldigen immer gut würde ich sagen
ich würde auch sagen es ist genau der
Punkt angesprochen hat nämlich wir haben
neue erkenn gewonnen über Corona ich
hatte am Anfang auch tiefe besorgt
deswegen Corona ich hatte Angst um es
offen zu sagen und ich war sehr
erleichtert als der Impfstoff kam das
habe ich einen großen Durchbruch
gehalten der Impfstoff war natürlich mit
dem was man sich davon versprochen hat
am Ende ihr eine Enttäuschung ja es ist
ja man ist möglicherweise auf Jahre
immun und so das ist so alles nicht
eingetreten das muss man auch deutlich
sagen ich frage mich aber warum ist das
in Deutschland eigentlich so dass da wo
andere sozusagen rationalisieren und
sagen wir haben neue Erkenntnisse wir
betrachten die Realität zu uns ist
vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm und ja
Corona ist ja auch teilweise schlimm
gewesen ich kenne Menschen die haben
beide Eltern verloren durch Corona das
muss man nicht ausblenden dass das ja so
war jetzt hat sich aber die Lage
verändert warum ist es in Deutschland so
dass dann manche anfangen zu
moralisieren und zu sagen also wenn du
dich nicht so so verhältst ein bisschen
schlechter Mensch und mit dir wollen wir
am besten nichts mehr zu tun haben und
so das ist ja passiert können Sie das
nachvollziehen die Argumentation dass
man da auch eine Reise der Entwicklung
durchmacht das einem erstmal versprochen
wurde die Impfung ist die große Rettung
man das natürlich glaubt und dann nach
und nach als wenn mehr Informationen
bekommen hat seine Haltung ändert
natürlich also kommt natürlich auch auf
den Wissensstand an den jeder hat ja
auch die persönliche Haltung eben
Emotionen ja ganz subjektiv hat jemand
Angst hat jemand keine Angst ja
gleichzeitig glaube ich dass wir relativ
früh wussten dass die Gefahr dieses
Virus nicht so groß ist wie sie
gezeichnet wird ja also ich lasse mir
noch gefallen für die ersten zwei drei
Monate dass man da vorsichtig war und
einfach nicht genau wusste was kommt
aber ab einem gewissen Punkt war einfach
klar ähm die Zombie Apokalypse bleibt
aus ja und ähm der Eindruck war wenn man
die Medien eingeschaltet hat die Zombie
Apokalypse findet jeden Tag statt dass
jeder das so kriegt so schnell ja und
genau
jeder kriegt das und irgendwie jeden Tag
hat immer mehr jemanden genau ist genau
das das war ja für die Medien in der
medienlogik war das natürlich ich sag
mal ein Glücksfall in Anführungszeichen
weil man jeden Tag eine neue Dramatik
schaffen konnte ja der erste Tode in
alten eine gute Nachrichten
aber ja der erste Tode in Altwarmbüchen
der zweite in Buxtehude der dritte innen
ja Frankfurt und so weiter und so hatte
man jeden Tag eine Dramatik jeden Tag
konnte man die Zahlen präsentieren und
wenn man sich dann aber mal die Zahlen
angeschaut hat muss man sagen sag mal
was war das eigentlich was habt ihr
eigentlich präsentiert nehmen wir doch
nur mal ja die Anzahl der neuen
Erkrankungen also ich meine wenn ich
jetzt 1.000 Leute teste und zehn
positive Fälle habe und am nächsten Tag
teste ich 2000 Leute und ich habe 20.000
20 Fälle und ich sage dann die ähm ja
die Zahlen haben sich verdoppelt ja das
hat natürlich damit zu tun dass auch
mehr getestet wurde und ähm das RKI hat
immer wieder auch Test Zahlen
veröffentlicht ähm ich habe das mal
recherchiert und habe nachgefragt auch
bei den gemeinen Landkreisen und so
weiter wie die Test Zahlen
zusammenkommen und Abgründe haben sich
aufgetan also entweder gab es keine
Zahlen oder sie hatten eben die Zahlen
aus den Tests sind aber nicht die
anderen Zahlen ja also man hatte einfach
keine gesamtestzahl und man hat im
Grunde genommen es gibt auch Leute die
sagen das war im Grunde genommen wie
eine testpandemie man testet und testet
und testet und man verschärft die
Situation subjektiv dadurch aber in der
Realität war es eben anders und also das
ist jetzt nur ein Ausflug in
Journalismus was man kritisieren kann ja
aber was mich viel mehr interessiert
wenn ich das vielleicht auch mal
ansprechen darf also ich würde gerne
noch kurz darüber diskutieren was
eigentlich in unserer Gesellschaft
passiert ist in dieser Zeit die
individuellen behalten wollen eine
kritische Stimme zu dieser
corona-pandemie und wir werden hier auch
die Frage stellen was ist mit den
anderen kritischen Stimmen wurden die
nicht genug gehört wie viel Einfluss
wurde genommen und diese zu unterdrücken
das gleich unser Thema hier bei 8:15 Uhr
Pause